hello i'm alvin welcome back to tasty's
making a big the show where i
make giant food for my friends today i'm
gonna be making a
giant subway sandwich because one of my
good friends inca
apparently loves subway and i think it's
gonna be fun to make a huge version of
one of their signature sandwiches so
first things first let's talk to inka
and see what kind of sandwich she likes
hello hello uh thank you for having me
back
and yes i do love subway we had subway
shops in hong kong and my mom would like
treat us
to sandwiches eating at subway with a
cookie
that was a treat so true all right ma'am
uh welcome to subway can i take your
order
so my go-to is the steak and cheese
that's what i want
and i want it on herbs and cheese i
think if they have that
i always go for that one i get like the
the usual stuff that they have in it
sometimes i swap out the american for
swiss cheese
barbecue sauce i love that uh would you
like your buns toasted ma'am
absolutely yes thank you well i will get
started on your order
and it'll be ready in a couple of hours
thank you
i'm very excited i haven't had one in so
long
okay bye bye
so the first thing gotta do is to make
the italian herb and cheese loaf and
we're gonna make a large version
first i'm gonna put some sugar and yeast
into this water let it bloom i'll put in
bread flour don't spill alvin we did
enough of that in the oreo episode
oh my god it's like a sugar crime scene
over here
into this i'm gonna put some shortening
and
[Music]
my little yeast baby over here has
gotten quite large
so he is ready
this is why i can't have nice things
faster this time alvin
there you go sometimes you just gotta go
fast if you go too slow
it ain't gonna work okay so todd has
been working
diligently and relentlessly for the past
10 minutes will now put you back
into the equipment graveyard uh room
where you belong
flower the surface get him out
he is so warm wow and because this
can only fit one batch of the dough our
wonderful culinary team
actually made another batch of the dough
in the back
now they're gonna get married
so soft it's like a big pillow
i'm going to gently lower my bread baby
into his slippery home
i could have said that one better so the
next thing on inca sandwich order
are green bell peppers and red onions
which i think
are sliced but raw in the sandwich to
kind of provide a nice balance
oh i have a lot to get through i'll see
if i can speed run this
now probably one of my most feared tasks
in all of cooking cutting red onions not
just
one not just two but six
i'm gonna cry
oh i can feel it that's only half of one
it's okay alvin you could be your own
fan
you should all be your own fans only
fans no
can't say that it's okay alvin you can
push through the tears i've done that so
much before
[Music]
yeah give me that
hello i'm back
modern problems require modern solutions
i feel powerful i feel like a new mane
just kidding it's not really working i
think the onions are finding
their way into oh my god it's not
working at all
this doesn't even help anymore because i
can't it's blocking the fan
any of you guys got like a straw or
something
so i can just i can suck it up
when i cook for my friends i try to cook
everything from scratch even though it
may hurt me sometimes but we're gonna
make barbecue sauce
so this is a new york times barbecue
sauce recipe i'm gonna put some
ketchup some apple cider vinegar brown
sugar
for some smokiness smoked paprika one of
my favorite ingredients
cumin freshly ground black pepper and
salt okay so this barbecue sauce is
very rapidly boiling and spattering
everywhere
like my mom when i don't take out the
trash
sorry mom tastes like barbecue sauce oh
that's good
okay seems like my dough baby
has grown up now
that he is nice and proofed we are going
to get him
into a nice sub shape this
is a bread recipe by the talented joshua
weissman
this bread comes from his subway
sandwich but better video
and we've scaled his recipe up a lot
this is probably not the best way to
do this but i'm not a baker i just make
big foods and just so that this guy
proves nicely i'm going to give him a
little foil cage
wrong way hours we're going to add some
more reinforcements
these are just i don't know we found
these in the back here wrapped them in
foil and they're big so we use them
kind of looks like a built like a space
shipper it's like something
elon musk would design we're gonna take
this breadship
and we're going to the moon everybody
good joke alvin so to make italian urban
cheese bread
we need italian urban cheese so we have
italian herbs and cheese it's very
complicated
hold your applause that's gonna go in
and there you have it herb butter my big
bread spaceship
has returned from the moon to get that
signature look
of the italian urban cheese sandwich and
brush this guy with
the herb butter so i can officially call
this
italian herbs and cheese i am curious
if there are any subway employees
watching please let me know how
many mistakes i'm making in the comments
the cheese goes on now this is just some
parmesan
kind of reminds me of like a olive
garden breadstick
i'm to go on a field trip this bread is
not actually going into the moon
we're putting them in an oven it's very
very different
into the oven you go oh
yeah bye-bye
[Music]
oh we i was supposed to exit frame
the steak and cheese sandwich is not
complete without steak
so we have some beautiful shave steak
which we got from the butcher
this cast iron very hot i don't know if
that's how they do it at subway but i
love steak and this is how i like to
cook it
here we go yeah
that's the sound i like to hear smells
really good
i don't want to crowd it so we're just
going to hang with that for now
some salt and pepper oh yeah look at
that
getting some good sear on this looking
pretty good
oh that's me okay
i'm gonna cook five more of those this
is a great day
so this is what a little bread baby
looks like
smells great cheese got nice and crusty
and
delicious and i heard the culinary team
is also making another one so we might
have an
extra long sandwich so in order to
connect the two
i am going to trim a bit and then we're
going to do the other one
a nice loaf of bread i'm going to save
this for sandwiches later
i'm going to attempt to cut this in half
oh that cuts really nicely come on
why didn't i go to the gym this is a
nice
nice loaf of bread and this is the
second loaf
the one that the culinary team made they
are really the backbone
of this show jackie and hip are great
well alrighty the base is set so one
thing that
inca specifically requested is that we
toast the buns this bread
is not gonna fit in an oven so we come
up with a solution
first we're gonna use a lot of butter as
as we do
on the show this is a heat gun because
it won't fit in the oven so
this is the only way we can toast this
here we go
oh yep that is definitely the smell of
butter toasting
okay so it's been about 15-20 minutes
the bun is finally toasted and i think
we can build this sandwich so
15 pounds of steak it's a lot of steak
cheeses
and green peppers and red onions and if
i'm correct subway starts off with the
vegetables first so
we are going to do that this kind of
reminds me of those sandwiches that you
might buy for those big birthday parties
or you know things like that
but this sandwich is for one person and
i hope she's hungry
next up my dear friend red onions
try to slice them thin so that they
don't get
too much of that acidic bite but we will
see
i think i got too much onions they
definitely did not need to go through
all that pain
and suffering and now my favorite part
the steak oh man this is great
i'm having a good time this is a lot of
steak
oh my god just take it easy here
i went to college for engineering that
is definitely not helping me now
this is so big all right let's do some
cheese
some nice slices of american
wow look at that now we have swiss
to melt the cheese we're going to use
the heat gun again
oh that's looking nice it smells so good
it kind of smells like the subway shop
not gonna lie
some nice pretty lettuce for the garnish
last but not least barbecue sauce
this is fun
we don't need that audio now
the final part don't mess this up alvin
[Music]
i think we did it guys wow
that's cool it looks good i'm excited i
hope inka likes it
i think it's time to call her up and let
her know that her order's ready
because here in the building she
currently cannot see
hi inka hi i can smell it i can't see if
i can smell it
ma'am your order is ready for pickup
on the count of three one two
three oh my god that is
huge it looks so much like a subway
sandwich i'm like a little shocked
maybe that's too big did you just say
too big it's too big
i'm on the wrong show no such thing
holy crap the bread is
like i don't know if people understand
how big this is like
hello how do people normally do this
they don't they don't normally do that
there's no way
oh my god mmm the flavor
is very similar not better that looks
like the exact same really
thanks alvin yeah this is really good
it's gonna take me a while to finish oh
my gosh
okay bye everybody i'm gonna continue
eating this
bye i can't wave because my hands are
hands are full
[Music]
you